joining me today is an Iraq war veteran
a political analyst and America's
favorite black gay Republican Rob Smith
welcome to the Reuben report thanks for
having me day America's favorite black
gay Republican that a lot of pressure to
put in a Twitter bio you know it's a lot
of pressure I feel that um about a year
ago about this time because I came out
as conservative a year ago and I out as
conservative came out fascinating phrase
that we're gonna talk we'll get into
that yeah absolutely but when I came out
I said I want something pithy
and catchy and kind of funny because
it's a joke you know America's favorite
black gay Republican I want there to be
a sense of humor in it because as you
know you know you use humor to bring
people in then you hit them with the
facts so a lot of people are gonna be
going wait a minute wait a minute these
guys are supposed to hate identity
politics but he's saying he's America's
favorite black Republican well here's my
thing with that I think that there's
number one all politics is identity
politics so everybody does identity
politics the left doesn't and the right
does it I think that since coming out as
a conservative the way I play identity
politics is this I'm black I'm gay I'm
an Iraq war veteran I'm all these
different things and they don't matter
about my politics because I can be all
of these things and still love America
yeah and the way the Left plays identity
politics is we hate you evil white men
or you know this is my 72 genders or all
this stuff so I feel like they use
identity politics not only in a super
negative and controlling way but as a
way to get people's votes it sucks
though to kinda have to do a little bit
of what they do to throw it in their
face right cuz like any time I I don't
mention that I'm gay that often yeah but
any time that I do I have no problem
mentioning it yeah more than happy to
talk about it
but any time that I do it really only is
to throw the use the way that they use
gay people yeah it's to throw that back
in their face like I have no I don't
want special credit for it yeah and I
mean there's there's no special credit I
think that for me when you get into my
history and you know
I'm gonna rock war veteran I protested
against Don't Ask Don't Tell and I came
out at 19 or I came out at 19 kind of
like to myself and a couple of friends
of my mother but when I got out of the
military around 21 years old because I
had to serve under Don't Ask Don't Tell
I said I'm done with closets so I'm
gonna be out as gay so being gay to me
has always kind of been a political act
yeah and when I was protesting it Gaston
asked him tell and getting arrested at
the White House and doing all these
different things it was always a
political act for me to be gay so even
coming out as a conservative and being
on the right and I'm proudly on the
right
being gay is still a political act
because I have to go into these spaces
and say I'm gay and this is why that
matters and this is how we can change
the party and change the idea of
conservatism to bring more people in do
you ever find that conservatives have
problems with gay people because people
keep telling me that all these
conservatives hate gay people and I go
to events all over the place all over
the country all over the world and I
meet all these conservatives I'm not
saying there are none yeah I have no
doubt there's a certain sect of bible
thumpers obviously that still do or some
people that have different religious
beliefs you know ben shapiro from an
orthodox jewish perspective not thrilled
with gay marriage yeah but now takes a
libertarian approach civil marriage I'm
okay with I don't need him to bow to my
beliefs yeah but I don't find that
there's any real pushback against gay
people from conservatives anymore I just
don't see it this is what I've seen and
and I've seen very very little in the
way of people having some problem with
me being gay the in my experience and
I've been god I spoke at the
Metropolitan Republican Club in New York
City and I speak at these Republican
events all over the country and it's not
so much I have a problem with you being
gay it's some people say one one person
came up to me and she said you know
you're so good-looking and you're black
and and you know you're all these things
like why do you have to talk about the
gay thing and I told her I was like I
talk about the gay thing because it's
very important for me to talk about it
because people need to know there are
gay conservatives out there that follow
me right now that are afraid to come out
and so I need to take this game as to
the space and let them know that it's
okay and also let you guys know that
you're missing out on a base of millions
of voters yeah
by doing things that can even be
true it is anti you think it's one of
those things where it sort of you have
to do it so that it can get to the point
that you don't have to do it yeah really
yes yeah and I was having the this
conversation with with Candice and I
shared this at the Blitzer rally over
the weekend as well doing identity
politics you do it now so that at a
certain point we don't have to do it
anymore so we have to say that I'm a gay
Republican or I'm a black Republican or
mag a black conservative or whatever you
want to say because as Americans we have
to break all that stuff down and figure
out what our identity as Americans is
and and that's the point for me yeah all
right so I want to talk about what it's
like coming out as a conservative as a
gay black man but let's just back up
yeah altogether tell me a little bit
about growing up yeah Emily that kind of
thing so I am from Akron Ohio one of the
biggest things that people like to say
to discredit black conservatives is that
we were all born wealthy we were all
born up on their upper middle class and
and what we're doing is we're just
trying to protect our privilege right
I'm from Akron Ohio well you weren't in
bel-air I was not in bel-air all right I
was in Akron Ohio and check the stats on
Akron Ohio anybody that doesn't know
where that is
went to be worse one of the worst public
school systems in the state you can look
on the website right now acting public
schools are rated D plus so I came from
a single you know mother household you
know I came from all this stuff and my
mother told me the story now I was too
young to remember but obviously I went
to kindergarten in a school that was in
my neighborhood and my mother tells me
the story about going to see me in
kindergarten one day and it was this you
know it's a 99% black school she the
people were just running around crazy
and she said I had to pull you out of
that school because I knew you weren't
gonna learn anything Wow
sent me to school all the way across
town this school was was mostly white
that doesn't make it better or made it
better was the property taxes and it was
just a more funded school so I was able
to get that kind of base went back to my
side of town for middle school in high
school which was just a terrible
experience I and I told people all the
time when they asked me about you know
sort of things and in the
old and Western civilization all that
I'm like look I went to Akron Public
Schools there are so many things that I
just do not know and so I had that
experience but in those days I'm
probably still today somebody that looks
like me that comes from where I come
from if I'm not dribbling a basketball
or doing whatever they like they don't
know what to do with you yeah so I was
not tracked in the college I wasn't
tracked in any of these things I
graduated high school at barely I think
was either 16 or barely 17 and just had
no path so I joined the military right
out of high school because I needed a
path I needed a job I needed something
to do I wish that I could say in my
military service is great and I love
this country and that five years that I
spent the military is probably the
greatest thing I'll ever do but I can't
lie and say that at 17 years old like I
was so patriotic I wanted to serve my
country like that it was a way for me to
move beyond yeah
well alright well before we get to that
I can't let anyone mention basketball I
got a boy you got any skills no I don't
I'm the word not like man ever I like
I'm terrible at basketball I don't want
to brag but I won most improved player
of the New York City game men's
basketball this year I think 2012 when I
was already like 37 yeah most improved
player at 37 yeah that's not bad that's
pretty good it's really funny that um
they have that gay basketball league
there there's a part of me that has
always wanted to try but I know it'd be
so bad and there are guys dunking I mean
it's a serious it's a seriously again
it's funny cuz I don't my I always for
me at least and I wonder for you like my
sports and my sexuality had nothing to
do with each other
yeah ever like I never brought my
sexuality when I out on the court anyway
you know what I mean like it wasn't like
that the only reason I joined that
league was at that point in my life when
I did I came out late and I finally was
like how let me just meet some I didn't
really like like the the bar scene or
like nothing there yeah like I didn't I
didn't like that and I was like oh maybe
if there's happened to be some gay
people that also like basketball maybe
yeah you know I'll find some friends and
I did find some friends there and it's
and half of them it's like you're gay
really like and
like dunks on you and you like some of
those guys like almost went pro yeah
that's how good they the weird thing
about kind of like being gay and not
only in my gay house we used to be a fat
kid yeah as well so I you're really
going for it oh my god everything did
you have a limp at any point I didn't
have a limp know that I did not have a
loan like a kid was not at like at all
so I didn't discover because there are
some sports I'm good at I played in in
the gay volleyball league in New York
City for a couple of years and now I'm a
pariah since I came out as conservative
oh jeez yeah yeah I thought they're all
telling ya right New York City gays
they're not very tolerant this is not so
much I am shocked but I discovered that
I am athletic and I discovered that I'm
great at volleyball great at tennis you
know like like lifting weights like
being in shape but that's kind of what I
discovered about myself kind of like I
don't want to say later in life but
definitely post 30 yeah that I actually
you know have some sports skills yeah
all right good so when you join the
military we already sort of out to
yourself now I'm talking about sexuality
now it's not politics that is certainly
not a conservative I was I was out to
myself I think in the way that a lot of
gay teens are you know I knew that I was
kind of like feeling away about guys
that I was supposed to feel about girls
but I don't know if I could really kind
of quantify it in that way and when I
went into the military they actually in
those days actually asked you are you
gay and I said no not only because I
didn't know how to define it at the time
but also I knew that that was a barrier
to to what I wanted to do you know so
being in the military I came out to
myself you know started exploring my
sexuality exploring all of that stuff
and like I said when I got done with the
military coming out was like a political
act I was like no more closet
yeah were you finding other gay people
in the military yeah like what is that
what was that like then I mean now now
where it's more accepted and donnatal
doesn't exist yeah and whatever the
thing about it's really funny how it is
now is that there are entire Instagram
accounts dedicated to gay guys in the
military it's called gay military dudes
and
and I love the fact that these these
young gay men in the military so open
about you know their sexuality and their
posting thought pics and they're doing
all this really like great you're saying
the military hasn't crumbled since and
it's not causing demoralization or
everyone still okay we still everybody's
still good okay back then there was this
this underground movement of gay people
gays and lesbians that were in the
military and I remember the very first
pride I went to I was on I was stationed
in Fort Carson Colorado so like right on
Colorado Springs and my very first pride
was Denver pride so I went there I think
it was like maybe 19 or 20 at the time
and that was my first time being around
a lots of other gay men at the same time
and it was the first time that you know
I was I was I was getting attention man
and then like people were looking at me
and I was like oh he's skewing us like
oh so this is what this is like so there
was a thriving underground gay culture
in the military how did were you afraid
to go out and go to a gay pride parade
while you're a service absolutely
because it's like if Don't Ask Don't
Tell was tricky because it was not only
you can't tell somebody that you're gay
but if you were discovered to be gay
then people would you know go up the
chain of command and kick you out but
the thing about it is and this is what
we always realized that nobody would
care because there are plenty of guys in
my unit that that knew I was gay and a
funny story there was a club called I
think it's now defunct called hide and
seek in Colorado Springs and they used
to be open to people under 21 after 2
a.m.
so I would be yeah yeah what yeah yeah
it would be open at 21
it would be open to people under 21
after 2 a.m. because it'd be like open
till 5:00 and they won't be serving any
booze so I was young in the militaries
like maybe 20 years old I would take a
nap at 10:30 and I don't wake up at 1:30
I would put on I had like black leather
pants and a tank top
he's insane crazy and then drive to
hide-and-seek and dance all night and it
was kind of it was a morgue a crowd but
it was mixed as well and I saw a couple
of my sergeants there one time at the
club and they saw they saw you and they
saw me and and they saw me and they were
like okay this is interesting and they
saw
we kind of like dancing with some
redhead and you know feeling my oats
yeah feeling myself but I remember being
terrified that weekend that they were
gonna help me that they were gonna like
tell my superiors or whatever it never
did well but you had it on them too
right I mean no they weren't gay they
were they were just like there with
their girlfriends because well I just
had a completely different yeah or not
in my head for the last 30 seconds yeah
no baby there was a girlfriend yeah oh
oh yeah
gotcha yeah I thought okay okay well and
so they did they didn't bust me out in a
lot of these guys are still my my
friends to this day my Facebook friends
and they see all the stuff that are
doing I'm here on their and coming out
as a Republican I'm doing all this and I
like Smith you know we always knew you
were gay you just didn't care
yeah you're a good soldier so I know
what most gay people feel about being in
the closet just how you can be as a
person it's just you know your your I
always felt like I was like lying all
the time accidentally like well it
wasn't even intention alized people
would ask me something and I could
immediately you know where were you last
night and I could just lie without
thinking you know generally it's a
really twisted dark it's not fun to
think back on that kind of thing
but for someone in the military that
Don't Ask Don't Tell
yeah do you think that affected your
ability to function as a soldier and I
think it did because the I think that to
me the biggest thing about being
closeted in the military was that it
affected the relationships that I was
able to have with my fellow soldiers
there was a wall there and if I was able
to just be gay and nobody cared that
wall wouldn't be there and and it's so
important when you're serving with
people to be able to be close to them
like literally to be able to to bring
your full self to work because not only
will be serving together I mean we
deployed together you know I did a tour
in Kuwait I did a tour in Iraq these are
the people that you're with these are
basically your family and you have to
hide a part of yourself and all the
times that they were hanging out or
doing things that we could become closer
I was separating myself from that
because I know that there was a part of
me that had to hide and so when I bring
all of that stuff now to to being gay
and being open as a conservative
and everything it is so important for me
to be open in that way because there I
can't have that wall there between me
and other conservatives and me and other
people in the movement and the younger
conservatives have been sitting like
these kids don't look hair yeah they
don't care some of the older ones need
to kind of be brought around a little
bit but man they don't care yeah do you
think it's just because young people
somehow have started to embrace a more
libertarian view of the world I mean
it's like we've got sort of you know
crazy leftism on one hand I've seen
catching fire all the time you really
pushed on us by the media yeah but then
I see and it I guess it's a little
selected by by who invites me to these
schools yeah but I see such a strong
libertarian like spirit with these yeah
it's not meaning that they're all
politically libertarians at every level
but like they just they want to live
their lives they want to love who they
love they want to smoke whatever they
want to smoke or whatever and I'm very
enthused by that I think that the
generation right now they really do just
they just want to let people live know
and they want to let people do the thing
they don't care about game they don't
care about transgender they don't care
about any of these different things they
just want to let people live and it's
really funny like the conversation I had
last night
at UCLA I had an event and it's so funny
because when I was protesting against
Toronto I was I was you know doing a lot
of lecture work and I was talking with
the young LGBT student groups and I was
just like you know you can be anything
you want to be let's empower you like
let's do all this stuff and I'm having
these same conversations with young
people who are afraid to come out as
conservative same thing day ya know it
is alright so alright let's just dive in
yeah and yeah because I really do feel
this now because I thought I know what
the closeted thing was like as in terms
of sexuality yeah but I see this now the
amount of emails that I get and when I
meet people on the street and they'll
kind of whisper it to me you know it's
not even they're not even saying cuz
yeah well they'll go you game and then
they'll go it's not even that they're
saying they're conservative you say
they're basically just saying they're
not a progressive yeah that they're not
they don't come from the woke monster
yeah you know it I mean and I and
they're walking around with that that
feeling that you described a moment ago
late it's a sexuality where you can't be
fully there with someone and I think
there are
there are quite literally I think there
are millions of people in the United
States that are walking around in a
closeted stay not because they're not
Caesar white supremacist or haters or
racists but just because they happen to
have either some conservative beliefs or
some libertarian beliefs or something
like that and I see it all the time and
I'm sure you probably get 10 times as
many messages as I do but you see it and
when you go have these conversations it
is the same conversations that I was
having with the young gay kids that were
afraid to come out I had a conversation
with the kid last night he was just like
man how do I come out to my friends as
conservative or how do I come out to my
friends as somebody who's like not a
leftist and this is what I always say to
them you know the real ones will stick
around the fake ones will go I promise
you that and when like a year ago I
remember sitting I was visiting my best
friend in Vegas and I was thinking about
I know from my experience you know being
very prominent and in the Don't Ask
Don't Tell thing that when you come out
as something like you're coming out to
make a statement and it has to be a
media moment and you have to get your
face out there because that's what gives
other people the strength to come out
and I was like man if I don't do this
somebody else is gonna do this because I
know I'm not the only black gay
Republican out there I have fans that
are that are black gay Republicans yeah
and and latina lesbian conservatives and
all sorts of stuff but I was like if I
don't do this somebody else is gonna do
this and somebody needs to do this
because these people need to know that
it's okay and when I take the hits and
you take the hits and Candace takes the
hits and all these other people takes
the hits it makes it easier for these
other people to come out so I've asked a
lot of my guests that have taken those
hit yeah this question I usually ask it
at the end but what do you think it is
about you that allows you to wanna take
the hits or maybe not even want that you
do whether you want to or not I'm
telling you the army builds something
that is indestructible indestructible
I served for five years I saw some
things in Iraq I saw some things
overseas and in not even outside of that
what the basic training does is it just
builds you up into somebody that has a
lot of discipline that can take a lot of
hits and I know enough about media and I
know enough about the people that are
making the moves right now I know that
it is important for me to do this
because and I'm telling you babe and
you've probably seen the shift in the
past five to seven years since you've
been doing this and have really been
blown up and traveling all all the world
there's a shift that's going on yeah and
I believe it's real and in three to five
years me being a black a conservative
this is gonna be like you know whatever
and I hate the fact that the gay
community I'm kind of I'm excommunicated
now you know so I'm not getting on
invites to the glade me either yeah yeah
we should start our own award we totally
should the the gay freethinkers hours
you know but you get excommunicated and
they're they're very high-level people
that I mean I used to get invited to all
this stuff in New York City because I
was a gay person in the media and when I
came out last year it was like it was
like silence so what does that really
tell you about these organizations and
sort of like GLAAD and these other
organizations that they're there for gay
people right they're supposed to be for
gay people and and if they subscribe to
intersectionality they should be for
black yeah on the rest of it but you're
saying you were in that they loved you
yeah you come out as conservative we're
done with you what it tells me is number
one that these organizations are not for
all LGBTQ people they're for LGBTQ
Democrats yeah first of all these are
leftist organization people really need
to understand this I know I say it all
the time but like I think that because
people just think GLAAD is for gay
people yeah this is for this / and it's
like no that's not really what's going
on here but what's but it really takes
work to get people to fully understand
why that yeah true and there used to be
and we talked about this a little bit
before we started before we started
filming there used to be a part of me
that wanted nothing more than to be kind
of like a gay so let me like oh I get to
go I get to go to the GLAAD Media Awards
and I get to go to the HRC red carpet
and I get to be and now I realize that
what I'm doing right now is so much
bigger than any of that stuff and I'm
not I'm doing this not for fame or
because the concept of fame has been
very strange to me and grappling with
with this newfound attention but it's
not about being with some d-list gay
celebrities on the red carpet it's
certainly not about being with even
though I might weigh usually the ones
that they're putting on the red carpet
they're not even gay half the time oh
yeah I told you I used to these red
carpets when I had a show on outcue and
I so I was interviewing people I was on
the other side of the red carpet and
mostly it was just Housewives of New
York drunk
these drunk plastic women that are like
oh I love gays let me tell you something
I can tell you a story and she will
remain nameless yeah but I actually did
something after oh I can tell you the
name is Esther yeah yeah but I was at
one of these award shows then this was
obviously before I came out when I was
still getting invited and this person
was a just a drunken sloppy mess and I'm
just like how is this celebrating gay
people how is this elevating us and so
what you have is with the glass of the
world this is about bullying Hollywood
celebrities into thinking that you know
what if you don't if you don't show up
to our red-carpet events you're not
supporting you know that the LGBTQ
community so that's what but what that's
all about the HRC is obviously of
leftist organization like very much so a
leftist organization and what irritates
me about this entire thing is that these
organizations were not started as
leftist organizations they weren't
supposed to be leftist well because at
that time they wanted real equality I
wanted equality under the law they
wanted the things that we have right now
hmm but to continue to get funding to
continue to be data centers for the
Democratic Party they have to go with
whatever far-left craziness and it's the
intersectionality cold and it's it's
being lectured by a queer Muslim at the
GLAAD Media work about how gays aren't
inclusive enough for for Islam and and
about you know how you how the LGBTQ
community needs to accept undocumented
people there's just like all this stuff
that was never it's never what our
movement was about and at the same time
for me as a gay man I know that hiv/aids
rates among young black gay men are
still exploding we have a huge problem
with math there's real stuff still going
on so what should they have done then
was there a moment that there should
have been a course correction so say gay
marriage gets passed down Ask Don't Tell
is gone yeah what do you think the
organization's if they had done it right
I mean is it is it do they close up shop
do they well that's what I think that's
what they were afraid of they were
afraid of now that we have this
quote-unquote true equality that the
close up shop Chris Chris Rock that
means great lines the cops need a
certain amount of crime yeah yeah and I
think that what happened after Don't Ask
Don't Tell repeal and marriage equality
were two of the biggest gay rights wins
of our generation like I think of our
lifetime and after that happen I think
that they just needed something else
they needed some more funding they
needed to to continue to be relevant so
they've gone into all of this
intersectionality far-left insanity and
what I see from being so open and being
a gay conservative out here is that
there is a large group of gays and
lesbians that are conservative that want
nothing to do with the leftist nonsense
they don't want to vote with their
sexual orientation they want to vote for
their values they want to vote further
with their pocketbooks you know they
they want to vote based on who they are
so you're saying let me get the street
yeah gay people are just like everybody
else just like everybody else they just
like everybody you're just lazy right
nuts
insane yeah and you'd think so where
where are the the right gay
organizations are there any I mean like
the live there anybody that you're out
there and you're like oh you guys are
doing some good grassroots okay related
to it is yeah I mean it's always it's
never going to be the HRC's and the
glads of the world it's always the
grassroots organizations it's your your
your Columbus pride you know it's your
the Brooklyn community pride Center it's
like these are the organizations that
our money really needs to go to because
these organizations are doing work on
the ground to like give young LGBT
people access to jobs and education and
all the stuff that the glads and the
HRC's of the world claim that they're
fighting for but really they're just
paying a lot of bigwigs like insane
six-figure salaries and in trying to get
Madonna on a red carpet and God love
Madonna we all love Madonna but that's
not the word yeah so I always try to
elevate the smaller organizations
because they need the time in the money
more than the big ones for the record
I'm more of a Tina Turner guy I'm over
Tina Turner yeah I hear she gives an
amazing show I haven't been yet I've
never said well I don't think she's
going live anymore I think she's done
tours you like she moved to like Sweden
or something I think she gave up her US
citizenship and she's just riding it out
[Music]